and obviously you know in things like
the halter used to working with green
screen but this is all it's all real yes
this is you know we really wanted to
stay away from the green screen
technology if we could we wanted to keep
this as his homemade as possible but
some scenes we had to put my face
literally on the other actor who played
both parts across from me for the show
you weren't talking to air though there
was an actor there no no that was one of
the things Derek's like we need a real
actor for you to be playing off of so
you know he hired an old friend of his
Gabe Fazio who lost the 20 pounds and
put on the 30 pounds who came in every
single day in character who gave the
performance of a lifetime that you that
you will never see which is really the
sad part of all this this guy was so
good at one point I said Derek why don't
we can't we just make him look like me
and so they had a mask made for him I
think I sent it to you guys yeah that a
picture of the mask
yeah do I did you get it yeah no I don't
know how much money you spent on that
mask that was like 20 grand man it just
looks like a lloween it looks [ __ ]
terrifying I mean look at that like even
at Halloween people wouldn't know who
you've gone as know like who he's
supposed to be no faster